Uh,
yeah.
Okay,
please.
1 million.
Oh,
because
no,
we can
go to the,
the
other side.
Feelings
inside.
He said the bed was really your favorite.
Sorry.
Any has autism.
She's trouble speaking to people face to face.
This really sweet though.
I'll make sure she get fit.
You guys,
we hope you really enjoyed the film.
Fireflies.
Just want to learn more about how we made this film,
why we made the film.
She got the behind the scenes video below.
So we made this video to raise awareness for autism and we invite you to make
your voices heard on this very important issue.
But joining the autism is campaign.
Learn more in the description box below.
And finally we have the fireflies.
Tee shirts here.
You can get yours at [inaudible] dot com remember,
doing good is contagious.
Jp.